So here's my version of the filterPlayground method.
You might have called your method something different,
that's perfectly fine it doesn't matter what you
called it. So I return, list of type conference.
And here I create the initial query where
I'm loading all the conferences sorted by name. And
then I add the filter. To filter on
city equals London. And I add the second filter,
to filter on topics equals medical innovations. Then I
call list on the query and I return the
results. You can also string everything together into one
long statement like this, but I prefer the code
to be broken up into smaller chunks for readability.
Now you know how to filter queries by property.
Obviously this function we just wrote is very hard
wired, and you would more typically let user pick
which values to filter on. And you'll learn how to do that soon.